It's like a religious right
for anyone raised in Texas.
You roll into the gas station,
look gorgeous
and pump your large vehicle to the brim.
With that sumptuous, glistening gas
that turn the state into an energy empire.
Smell that?
It's a rush of petrochemical pheromones
straight to the brain.
The blessing of oil has given
Texas many wonderful things.
The great fracking prairies of west Texas,
JR Ewing, Enron,
and of course the petro
paradise of Pasadena
with its chemical factories that celebrate
humanity's ability to harness
and then dominate nature.
Imagine my surprise then
to learn that right here in Houston,
there were people like this,
a pair of anti-petro hippies.
These two guys say they can
make things like fertilizers,
and cleaning products, and plastics
without any oil or natural gas at all.
And they say they can do
it at this factory which,
if you believe them,
does not produce one ounce of waste.
In honor of Jerry Jones
and all that Texas considers Holy
I decided to investigate this
place and these bold claims.
I busted right on in to Solugen.
Because Houston is awesome,
it doesn't really believe in zoning laws.
You can drive through a
neighborhood like this
and then run smack dab
into a chemical plant.
In this case,
the headquarters of Solugen.
The company has raised more
than $420 million so far
and counts noted science expert,
Leonardo DiCaprio, as
one of its investors.
Tell me the big idea
nobody's ever heard of
synthetic biology or any
of this stuff before,
what's the very core thing
you guys are going after?
Yeah, I think like there's a few ways
to think about what we do.
At the simplest level,
the question that we want to answer
is how do we use carbon dioxide
to make valuable chemicals and materials
that we interact with every day?
The star of the show here
is something that
Solugen calls a Bioforge.
The big idea behind all
this machinery is this:
you feed some enzymes with corn syrup
and because they're special enzymes,
they kick off useful
molecules that can be refined
and then used for all sorts of tasks.
In short, you're making chemicals
but using corn instead of
oil or gas to produce them.
As Solugen sees it,
it's technology strips a lot of steps out
of the chemical making process.
And most importantly for mother earth,
eliminates all the noxious waste
of traditional chemical manufacturing.
I actually grew up in Houston.
I, you know,
Pasadena is not that far away
and it's famous as like
this chemical industry town
sort of notorious for
the smells and things
that come out of there.
So, you know,
if I think about the
traditional chemical process,
what goes into that and why
is it notorious in some ways,
for all the waste products?
If you think about a chemical plant,
like the plants in Pasadena
that you grew up with,
all they're really trying to do
is convert a feedstock
into a valuable product.
And when you guys talk about feedstock,
that's just the base thing
that you're starting with-
The raw material.
The raw materials.
And the problem with
the traditional chemicals industry is
you can't convert your feedstock
directly to the product.
What happens is you
make this alphabet soup
of other side products,
these toxic emissions, all the smells,
all these waste streams.
So really what the Solugen innovation is,
Gorab and I coming together,
is about, okay, well,
what if you could convert a
feedstock directly to a product?
What Solugen is claiming
is that it has developed
a completely new way
of making chemicals.
That's both more efficient
than conventional methods
and, almost disturbingly, pollution free.
Okay, so, sugar, water, carbon go in
and then what comes out at the end?
Our products, yeah.
The product, and no,
and is there water waste,
but it's kind of cleaner?
Zero
It's just the product?
Okay, so, there's like nothing?
That's the beauty of like,
the insight that we had was just like,
you'll have no air emissions, no water.
It's a huge advance.
Because of like CRISPR and-
Precisely.
And just being able to
change the DNA of it?
Exactly.
Change the DNA and then
fundamentally the enzyme
in a way that lets it do things we want.
My tour of Solugen began in its labs.
The scientists here must
discover new enzymes
that will perform certain tasks
and then figure out how
to grow and feed them.
This is where we actually
engineer those enzymes.
There's the physical wet lab space,
but then we've got a server in Germany
that is running millions of computations
on this little enzyme to figure out
how do we keep optimizing
it to make it better
for that reactor?
Once we designed that enzyme,
we now have to express
it at high enough titers
that we can use it in
our industrial processes.
This is a small version
where we actually ferment the proteins.
And the way we do that here
is we've let it live in this fermentor
and we feed it, its
nutrients, let it grow,
and, as you can see, this
started like pretty clear,
but see how it's dark now?
That means that protein
is starting to express
really, really well.
Everything else that you see here
is downstream processing to
separate that protein out
and isolate it so we can
put it into the reactor.
It all sounds easy enough now,
but Gorab and Sean have been
on a long and winding journey
to figure this stuff out.
How did you two meet and
come up with this idea
in the first place?
People think we made the story up,
but we didn't, right?
So like I'm actually a physician scientist
studying cancer biology,
discovered really cool,
like, reactions that
make molecules in cancer.
Started with hydrogen peroxide.
And Sean was at MIT doing
his chemical engineering PhD
on the production of hydrogen peroxide
at massive scales using
metal catalyst, right?
So we're working on the same problem,
but just from-
Enzymes metals, right?
It's always just a story of luck.
Like lucky that we met,
lucky we had this idea.
Then what was really lucky is
our first customer saw our pitch to MIT
and they said, "Hey, if you
make this, we'll buy it."
And so actually like we
loaded our first product
in the back of my Subaru
and we drove it to our customer in Dallas.
Like a tank of something?
It was just a one gallon bottle.
It was a mixture of
gluconic acid and peroxide
that we called Bioperoxide.
So it'd be used for?
For a cleaning hot tubs.
Yeah, so we just-
It's not glamorous, actually.
No, there's nothing
glamorous about this.
But the best part
is like, we thought it was amazing.
So like we made this first sale
and then I told my wife
I was like, I'm gonna quit my job.
She was like, you made like what?
She was like "how much was the sale?"
Like, $200?
And this machine,
this is like the first thing that
you guys worked on?
Where it all started.
Yeah, yeah.
So this is the original one we've got,
I don't know why that's there,
but yeah, multiple times people have tried
to throw this away,
but yeah, no, I,
Gorab and I, we hand built the system.
With this particular machine
when you were trying to develop the enzyme
and your technique, there was just like,
nothing like this that you could buy?
So there are no enzymatic reactors.
So yeah, you can't go
into Google and be like,
I want to buy an enzymatic reactor.
And where did you build this?
In somebody's apartment, or?
We rented some lab space
behind Love Field Airport in Dallas.
We rented some lab space.
And then this was built
from Home Depot parts.
We actually had to take out
ceiling panels in the lab
to fit it in.
How long did it take you to do that?
This was,
I would say this was probably
a two or three week build.
And now these guys'
bizarre machines are all grown
up and rather spectacular.
And so this is the first
commercial Bioforge.
All the extra piping and everything,
I mean, what's going on all
around this on the sides?
From any point in the plant,
you can essentially send
material anywhere else
in the plant.
This is how you build a
zero discharge facility
with no waste stream.
This is corn syrup.
I kind of jokingly say that this tank
contains 10 million calories.
10 million calories?
That's 10 million calories, yeah.
So once it works its way
through the entire plant,
then our end product is
stored in these tanks.
And so we can essentially
take our four ingredients,
blend them with the
material in these blue tanks
and then ship finished goods
into the concrete industry,
into ag, and into water treatment.
How'd you know that's supposed to go off?
I built this.
Much of what happens
in this jungle of pipes
relies on Solugen's new-age enzymes.
But some of the action requires
old fashioned chemistry
in the form of metal catalysts.
It's the metals and enzymes combined
that let the company make
just about any chemical
known to man.
Plastics, gasoline,
whatever you want to make,
it depends on what type
of catalyst they touch.
Here you can make a completely
different product profile
as this catalyst.
Like if you come to me
as a customer and say,
"Hey, I want to make nylon."
There is a catalyst in there
that when paired with an enzyme
can make nylon, the
starting precursor to nylon.
So that's the beauty of
kind of what we're doing
is like we've got this
sweet hundreds of enzymes,
hundreds of metal catalysts.
Now it's just mixing and matching
based on what customers need
to make the product that they want.
One of the biggest promises
behind this technology
would come from sucking carbon
right out of the atmosphere
and injecting it into
the Bioforge as feed.
Instead of the corn syrup
that they're currently using.
Solugen thinks it knows how to do this
and is in the midst of
perfecting its techniques.
Basically that plant out there,
it makes about 10,000
metric tons of product,
but it removes about 30,
greater than 30,000 metric
tons of carbon dioxide,
which is pretty remarkable
on a mass balance basis.
How can we use synthetic
biology and marry it
with traditional
petrochemistry techniques?
Because we need both of those things
to really capture the essence
of using CO2 as a feedstock.
We were working with the corn story now,
which is a great CO2 sink,
but the reality is where we want to go is
how do we just take that CO2 from the air
and make the things that we want?
The Biforge only opened
a couple of months ago
and some of the claims around it
seem somewhere between bold
and the stuff of green tech fantasy.
Solugen, though, is actually
making things already
and does have some paying customers.
Our chemicals are used in like concrete
and building material and like wood glues.
So all the boring things that
make up the world around us,
it turns out some of those
chemicals that are used
are not super safe,
but we might have an
opportunity to replace them
with safer bio-based options.
Because this is like
the tip of the iceberg.
If you look at what you can
do with the Bioforge concept,
you can go after 90% of the molecules
in the chemicals industry.
Since I grew up in Houston,
I knew what needed to happen next.
It was time to engage
in the great tradition
of eating TexMex food.
It would be through the
power of queso and margaritas
that I would learn how this
whole Solugen thing began
with Sean and Gorab running
a rickety early version
of the Bio-Forge all by
themselves, Walter and Jesse style.
You know, I mean, it just seems like it
must've been a crazy experience
to be doing the "Breaking Bad" thing
and kind of seeing where it was going to,
just imagining where it would go.
We were really just two guys
running this old PVC reactor.
Like I remember one night in the lab.
I mean, we were behind Love Field airport,
a pretty seedy area.
Like we were just working
and someone threw a bowling
ball through the window.
The funny thing is,
where did they get the bowling ball?
It's so specific.
At that beginning stage was this kind of,
you're seeing where it was going to go
or you're like, we're going to make-
No, it was trying not to run out of money.
But were you thinking
this could be a chemistry company
or was it just we're onto
something interesting-
I mean, if we allowed
ourselves to dream the dream,
yeah.
It's interesting
because it's not that there
was any particular aha moment.
Like I would say at the beginning,
it's like,
I think we were doing it
because we really liked
the science.
We submitted, I think,
50 patents in 2020 alone.
I know you guys are in a business
and you're in this to make money.
You've discovered this cool thing,
but isn't this a little bit
like when people, you know,
if you guys are as successful
as you kind of hope to be,
and this does as much good as it could,
wouldn't be able be upset if
you guys have the monopoly
on all these recipes and processes?
I totally get that.
And I think that's where we
think a little bit bigger,
right?
Where it's like, well, what if-
I always use this example,
it's a silly example.
Airbnb is the largest hotel
but it doesn't own a single property.
Uber is the largest cab fleet,
doesn't own a single cab.
What if there's a future
where we are the largest chemical company,
but we actually end up not
owning many chemical assets,
eventually, and we give
people access to these things?
And so democratize access
to like this technology.
So anyone can enable it and access it.
These hippies do not have the,
I'll drink your milkshake ethos
of the best Texans.
But they do seem smart
and well-intentioned.
If the great Roger
Staubach will forgive me,
I'll even wish them the best of luck.